se suspende el proyecto minero Dominga
en Chile por lo menos por ahora la
decisión la tomó un comité conformado
por seis ministros del gabinete después
de que en mayo de 2022 la Corte Suprema
les enviara una batalla jurídica que
comenzó en 2017 de forma unánime este
comité de ministro resolvió acoger las
doce reclamaciones y por lo tanto
queda con una evaluación de favorable el
proyecto minero portuario Dominga la
compañía andes Iron recurrirá la
decisión su proyecto de 2500 millones de
dólares es para explotar hierro y cobre
durante 22 años pero los ambientalistas
se oponen porque esta es una de las
zonas marinas más biodiversas del
planeta la mina el tofu y el puerto de
totoralillo Norte serían en el centro
del país sobre el Pacífico a 16
kilómetros de la comuna la higuera y
también muy cerca de la reserva nacional
pingüino de Humboldt donde se encuentra
el 80% de esta en peligro que la
corriente de Humboldt que es la que
tenemos en Chile va de Sur a Norte
Entonces al norte de estos proyectos
está la reserva más antiguas de chile
que es donde
habitan
de Humboldt pero también
las ballenas Entonces por ejemplo un
derrame de hidrocarburo eso acabaría
irreversiblemente con eso ecosistema
Lizbeth vandermare también le explicó a
France 24 que ellos impulsan que la zona
se ha declarada como área Marina
protegida pues Dominga no es el único
proyecto una termo eléctrica que se
llama barrancones esa fue el primer
proyecto que se baja la zona por su
importancia biológica después vinieron
dos termoeléctricas más ahora un
megapuerto y hay otro megapuerto que se
llama cap que también está situada en la
zona entonces este tiene un gran interés
y creemos que estos intereses hay que
cerrarlos para siempre en esa zona y
hasta que haya una nueva decisión no se
explotará hierro y cobre en esta zona de
Chile